Захисні костюми для медиків від українських дизайнерів.
Маски з вишивкою в українському стилі.
І не китайські, а українські тести для діагностування коронавірусу.
Так український бізнес відреагував на виклики епідемії.
У київській молекулярно-генетичній лабораторії Diagen
над тестами на наявність коронавірусу почали працювати ще в січні,
тільки-но китайці оприлюднили геном вірусу.
Станом на початок квітня тут вже виготовили ПЛР-систем на 10 тисяч аналізів.
Їх купують і державні клініки, і приватні. Вони вже пройшли валідацію.
У нас з цим дуже важко, бо треба було збирати заражені зразки,
але держава ніяк не сприяла тому, щоб ці зразки безпечно були надані розробникам.
І це загальмувало нас дуже сильно, десь на місяць.
Через нерозуміння держорганів, чим вони можуть допомогти в такій справі,
як вітчизняні розробки. Але нічого, впоралися...
А у компанії "Нібулон", що є одним з лідерів на ринку сільськогосподарської продукції,
з'ясували, що прилад, який визначає наявність генетично модифікованих організмів
у харчових продуктах, може виявити коронавірус методом ПЛР-досліджень.
Компанія докупила реагенти та безкоштовно відправила своє обладнання
до Миколаївського обласного лабораторного центру МОЗ України.
А ось санітайзери почали виготовляти в іншій аграрній компанії - Укравіт.
Вона спеціалізується на виготовлені засобів захисту рослин та мікродобрив.
50 тисяч літрів дезінфекційних засобів безкоштовно передали лікарням та армії.
Виріб виявився таким затребуваним, що після епідемії
планують постачати цю продукцію на продаж.
У майбутньому зробимо. Люди привчаться більше до гігієни,
бо змінюється клімат і зараз, на жаль, перший глобальний виклик, який склався,
тому людям треба бути готовими.
Ми додамо цей продукт в нашу "лінійку", щоб на постійній основі він був.
Робота над весняно-літньою колекцією в студії дизайнерки Людмили Кисленко зупинилась.
Ось працювали, бачите? Працювали, кроїли, щось робили…
Тепер замість вишуканого жіночого одягу тут шиють захисні костюми для лікарів.
Так, творча робота була у нас, а тут шиємо для медиків, для медицини…
Своє невелике підприємство Людмила Кисленко вирішила перепрофілювати,
коли в Україні почалася епідемія коронавірусу,
а з лікарень почали надходити невтішні новини:
у медиків для захисту немає найнеобхіднішого.
Ви навіть собі не можете уявити, наскільки великий дефіцит костюмів, ось просто немає.
Якщо нашим центральним лікарням потроху щось дають, то те, що мені
пишуть з віддалених селищ, - це катастрофа.
Люди, працівники швидкої допомоги, в рибальських костюмах, їздять на виклики.
Через закриття ринків Європи та Америки без замовлень залишилася компанія "Текстиль-Контакт"
Але виробництво тут не простоює.
Вже кілька тижнів на швейній фабриці в Чернігові в промислових масштабах
шиють захисні костюми та маски для медиків.
Умовно кажучи, маска нам обходиться 8 гривень 60 копійок,
і за такі гроші ми її продаємо. Це не дає можливості заробити,
але дає можливість тим підприємствам, які займаються пошиттям цієї продукції на замовлення,
хоча б зберегти робочі місця, компенсувати хоч якось рівень неминучих витрат і вижити.
і чекати кращих часів, коли знову зможемо шити сукні, кофти та джинси.
А поки на власному текстильному комбінаті планують запровадити технологію
з виготовлення тканини з антивірусними властивостями.
А в майбутньому запустити вже сертифіковане виробництво як тканин, так і медичного одягу.
Ми вивчаємо питання додаткового обладнання, яке дозволяє
пошити медичні костюми - правильні з точки зору затверджених МОЗ і ВООЗ.
Там спеціальні вимоги і до приміщень, спеціальні вимоги і до швів.
Це має бути,, умовно кажучи, шов, який б'ється ниткою,
а спеціально спаяні шви, які термострічкою спеціально клеяться.
"Карантинити на стилі" пропонує львівська студія "Гойра".
Жіночка каже, що в неї є така сукня і хоче таку маску. І з цих заготовок будемо робити таку маску.
Бренд вирішив тимчасово переформатувати роботу своєї студії
та зосередився на виготовленні масок для обличчя.
Їх безкоштовно роздають медикам та онкохворим.
Вишивка - це є своєрідний оберіг і генетичний код для кожного українця.
Дивлячись на цю маску, кожен із нас буде отримувати трошки позитиву і хорошого настрою.
А хороший настрій - це запорука зміцнення імунітету.
Епідемія коронавірусу показує, що в Україні є соціально відповідальний бізнес,
який готовий підстрахувати державу там, де вона не справляється.
Фінансово допомагають благодійники і волонтери.
Втім, і в тих, і в інших ресурсів надовго не вистачить,
тож держава повинна подбати про розвиток промисловості
суспільно важливих товарів та підтримку вітчизняних науковців.